THE EVENING.
IF ANYTHING BREAKS WE WILL
COME TO IT.
WE TURN NOW TO THE IMPENDING
SUPREME COURT NOMINATION.
WE START WITH A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON JUDGE AMY CONEY
BARRETT.
SHE IS THE MOTHER OF SEVEN.
INCLUDING TWO ADOPTED CHILDREN
FROM THE COUNTRY OF HAITI.
SHE IS A PRACTICING CATHOLIC.
JUST LIKE JOE BIDEN AND NANCY
PELOSI.
SHE HAS EMBARKED ON A
SUCCESSFUL AND IMPRESSIVE
CAREER AS AN ATTORNEY.
AS A PROFESSOR.
AND AS A JUDGE.
IF CONFIRMED, SHE WILL BE THE
YOUNGEST PERSON ON THE BENCH.
SHE WILL BE THE FIFTH WOMAN
EVER TO SERVE ON THE
U.S. SUPREME COURT.
JUDGE BARRETT IS KNOWN AS A
TEXUALIST.
ONE WHO VALUES THE MEANING OF
THE U.S. CONSTITUTION.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
THE FIRST AND THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
SHE ARGUED IN FAVOR OF GUN
RIGHTS AS IS IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
INCLUDING FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN CONVICTED OF THE
NONVIOLENT CRIMES.
SHE IS A STRONG DEFENDER OF
DUE PROCESS.
AND THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
ON THE ISSUE OF ABORTION, IN
SPITE OF THE LIES THE LEFT
WILL TELL YOU, JUDGE BARRETT
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS
PERSONALLY PRO-LIFE BUT
EXPRESSED DOUBTS THAT ROE v.
WADE WILL EVER BE OVERTURNED.
AGAIN, SHE IS AN ORIGINALIST.
BELIEVES IN PRECEDENT AND SHE
SAID SO.
SHE BELIEVES IN COEQUAL
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND
SEPARATION OF POWERS.
SHE NOT AN ACTIVIST JURIST.
SHE IS NOT TRYING TO WRITE OR
RECREATE SETTLED LAW AND SHE
WILL NOT LEGISLATE FROM THE
BENCH.
DESPITE WHAT YOU WILL HEAR,
WHICH WILL BE A LOT OF LIES
PREDICTABLY FROM DEMOCRATS,
JUDGE BARRETT NEVER DIRECTLY
RULED ON ANY ABORTION CASE.
SHE DID ONCE ARGUE IN FAVOR OF
JUDGES RECUSING THEMSELVES FOR
CONSCIENCE ISSUES OR RELIGIOUS
REASONS SURROUNDING IMPORTANT
CASES LIKE THE DEATH PENALTY.
IN OTHER WORDS, ISSUES OF
CONSCIENCE.
I THOUGHT IT MATTERED TO
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT.
JUDGE BARRETT IS
EXTRAORDINARILY WELL
QUALIFIED.
SHE IS EXTREMELY SMART.
EDUCATED WITH A LOT OF
EXPERIENCE.
EXTREMELY IMPRESSIVE
INDIVIDUAL.
PROFESSIONAL ON EVERY LEVEL.
SHE IS A CONSTITUTIONALIST.
THAT MEANS THE LEFT WILL AND
IS ALREADY VILIFYING HER.
NOW THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE
AND THEY WILL WANT YOU TO
BELIEVE SHE IS AN EXTREMIST
MONSTER WHO IS UNFIT TO SERVE.
THEY WILL LIE.
THEY WILL SMEAR.
THEY WILL SLANDER.
THAT IS WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT
THEY DO.
YAHOO! NEWS PUBLISHED AN
ARTICLE THAT READS "THIS IS
AMY CONEY BARRETT, THE
POTENTIAL R.B.G. REPLACEMENT
WHO HATES YOUR UTERUS."
THAT IS A LIE.
THEY WONDERED IF THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE "HANDMADE’S
TALE."
AND UNDER SCRUTINY AND REUTERS
WAS ONLY ONE OF MANY OUTLETS
THAT ATTEMPTED TO USE THE DISP
TOPIAN STORY TO SMEAR HER
FAITH.
DID ANYONE QUESTION BIDEN’S
FAITH?
NO.
ANYONE QUESTION PELOSI’S
FAITH?
NO.
NOR SHOULD THEY.
NOR SHOULD ANYONE.
THAT IS BELIEVE THEM, THEIR
CONSCIENCE, THEIR CHURCH AND
THEIR PERSONAL BELIEF IN GOD.
IT’S NON’S BUSINESS.
IT HAPPENS TO BE A FACT THEY
ARE AT ODDS WITH THE CHURCH
DOCTRINE ON MANY ISSUES BUT
THAT IS NONE OF OUR BUSINESS.
NEWSWEEK PUBLISHED BASELESS
ATTACK AGAINST JUDGE BARRETT
SO DID OTHER SO-CALLED NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS.
THE ATTACK ON JUDGE BARRETT’S
CHARACTER DIDN’T STOP THERE.
THIS THE BEGINNING OF WELL, A
MONTH OF HELL FOR HER AND HER
FAMILY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO I THINK THE STAKES OF
THIS NOMINATION ARE VERY
CLEAR.
IF IT IS IN FACT, BARRETT, SHE
IS SOMEONE WHO WILL IMPLEMENT
DONALD TRUMP’S AGENDA ACROSS
THE BOARD.
>> 48-YEAR-OLD AMY CONEY
BARRETT IS A MOTHER OF SEVEN,
WHO HAS WON OVER RELIGIOUS
CONSERVATIVES FOR HAVING
ANTIABORTION VIEWS.
>> BUT IN SOME WAYS SHE WOULD
BE THE OPPOSITE OF RUTH BADER
GINSBERG.
SHE IS A PRETTY CLEAR OPPONENT
OF ABORTION.
THAT MAY BE A KEY POINT FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
HE WILL WANT TO NOMINATE
SOMEBODY WHO IS DETERMINED TO
OVERTURN ROE v. WADE.
>> THERE IS CIVIL RIGHTS AND
LABOR UNION RIGHTS AND GAY
RIGHTS AND WOMEN’S RIGHTS.
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
ROE v. WADE COULD BE UNDONE